hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we all
know about movies they're so bad they're
good
you're happenings your bird demyx your
rooms it seems everybody has a film
that's so incredibly awful that they
can't help but laugh at it making it
enjoyable good but this got me thinking
if it can work so well one way why can't
it work so well another way can a film
be so good that it's bad how would that
be possible
what does it even mean you don't have an
incredible meal and say it's so
delicious it tastes awful so how could
this work for film how could a movie
have so many positive things that it
could ultimately equal something
negative I didn't really know which
examples did mixing how this was kind of
a different idea so I decide to look at
films that everybody seemed to love but
just never seem to grab me not bad by
any means but something about them just
didn't move me like I think they were
meant to as a critic it's kind of
embarrassing when you find a film that
either does or doesn't work for you but
you can't really explain why that's your
job to point out strengths and
weaknesses and what we can learn from
them but I think everybody critic or not
has several films they just can't get
into and don't really know how to
explain why because they themselves
don't know you can't say it's bad you
can't even really find anything wrong
with it
but there's a strong disconnect that
shouldn't be there yet for some reason
it is could this so good it's bad idea B
the reason was something so great at
hitting so many people that it fails to
have a personal touch with you is it
just difference of opinion could it be
something more I started putting
together a list of movies that left this
kind of impact on me and keep in mind
this is my list if you have strong
opinions on these movies great this is
just to give you examples of the idea
I'm talking about what should
technically be great but it doesn't feel
that great for some reason the first one
I could think of was the Truman Show
everyone said this was a phenomenal
clever comedy slash drama way ahead of
its time and there was when I saw the
movie I didn't really see anything wrong
with it Gary was buying the direction
was smart the writing had all the right
notes so how
I wasn't crying at the same time Jim
Carrey was crying how come even though I
wanted to know what was gonna happen at
the end I wasn't quite at the edge of my
seat could it be the style was too good
creating too much of a disconnect from
the character even if so that distance
would help me see him as an average Joe
still making me feel sorry for him
in a strange way distance in this kind
of movie could actually help me feel
more for was it too much talking and not
a visual emotion it doesn't seem like it
the visuals are stunning and very
strongly emulate what the characters are
going through everything seems right for
a great movie so how come I don't feel
the same thing that I felt in other
great movies why am I only slightly
invested but not incredibly invested
let's try another one with a powerhouse
of great actors based on one of the
greatest plays ever written the crucible
based on the Arthur Miller classic this
movie about one of the darkest times in
American history not only works as its
own disturbing tale but also as an
allegory to the vehm prominent McCarthy
trials as well as a gathering place for
some of our best actors like Daniel
day-lewis Joan Allen and Winona Ryder
again everything seemed perfect the text
is perfect the actors are perfect the
direction seemed perfect so why wasn't I
seeing it as one of the greatest things
ever made
it was suspenseful it was emotional but
it wasn't great everybody talks about
the power of the play but nobody talks
about the power of the movie which is
almost line for line from the play again
I don't know anybody who hated it but
it's hard to find a person nowadays who
says they love it what was missing what
could possibly be missing everything
needed seems to be right there maybe
they're too safe to leave that big an
impact well that wasn't the case in Bram
Stoker's Dracula this by any means is an
amazing film combining old-school
effects with new technology telling the
story of Dracula the closest to the book
while also having one of the most
amazing visual styles ever put to cinema
it was faithful it was smart it was
clever it was amazing absolutely amazing
and yet the reaction from everybody is
always the same it
these are again great performances and
for the most part amazing visuals and
even clever storytelling but still a lot
of people including myself can't quite
get that sucked into it despite it being
very different and unique from any other
telling of Dracula while also strangely
enough being the most faithful maybe
some of it has to deal with the element
of surprise films like in the bedroom
and Cinema Paradiso were nominated for
Oscars when they came out and you can
clearly see why they deliver the good
movie you think you're going to get and
that's about it you'll watch a little
bit of the film and you can figure out
very quickly what kind of movie it's
going to be and it does it with a lot of
skill and passion but nevertheless
you're aware of what you're going to get
so nothing really catches you off-guard
I don't know if it's unpopular to say or
not but you can kind of say the same
thing about et everyone thinks this
invented the hiding acute something
story but this has been done many times
in movies prior bTW just made it the
most popular inspire the most ripoffs
with that said even though it's done
well don't you know every step it's
going to take even though it does it
beautifully and with great patience can
you predict every moment before it
happens now this isn't always a bad
thing we've seen lots of other movies we
could predict beginning to end and we
still love all these films I've listed
add their own uniqueness to make them
stand out even if we can kind of predict
them so why is it so hard for so many to
get behind them nowadays et was huge
when it first came out and we still
remember it but admit it it's not as
celebrated now as it was back then
unlike some other children's classics
that get more and more popular with time
but again there's seemingly nothing
wrong with it or any of the other movies
I was talking about everyone can
identify with them but they're not
generic they stand out but not for the
wrong reasons
they accomplish exactly what they were
meant to accomplish they're actually
about as perfectly told as movies in
these genres could be told
so how come many of us can't get into
them as much as we should be getting
into them does it make sense to
criticize the film for being too good I
then started to think about my favorite
movies and what made them stand
Brazil for example is my favorite film
with its dark surreal comedic take on an
overblown Orwellian future but even I
acknowledge it has a few problems the
actions not always that grade the pacing
can be slow in a few areas the plot can
be hard to follow at times
Amadeus another one of my favorites it's
about as perfect a movie as you can get
but even it took the risk of throwing in
historical fiction purposefully getting
things false thus always making it worth
conversation I don't think the film
would have been as strong if it just
told the straightforward story of Mozart
it would have been good but not great as
I started thinking more and more about
my favorite films I started to realize
perfection really does lie in
imperfection it's kind of like the
example I used in my Smurfs review when
I said what would you rather watch a
Mario game where everything goes one
speed or a Mario game where there stops
and mistakes the flawless version is
interesting and takes great skill but
the one with the mistakes is more
suspenseful and therefore more engaging
maybe the same way we want good things
and bad things to happen in a movie
story maybe we also want the movie
itself to have good things and bad
things
perhaps we do want to see stuff wrong
with it
perhaps it emphasizes how human it is
how fallible it can be so we know that
when we reach the truly great moments
it's all the more deserved they say
great entertainment should feel flawless
but maybe it's the flaws that make us
realize that is great not that any of
these movies I mentioned before are bad
quite the contrary
just a story about a producer who
applauded at the end of every movie no
matter what it was because he knew how
hard it was for a movie to give me any
film is difficult to get working with so
many people financers producers and so
forth all trying to turn out their idea
of a good product the fact that a film
can be perfect to a fault is not
something to be ashamed of it's actually
quite a my herbal but at the same time
it does make you realise how important
it is to have chinks in the armor a
slight dent in the vase to show it was
made by human hands what is film but a
means to realize and treasure how unique
being human is and the more human of
film feels including having the faults
the more we're most likely going to
identify with it again that's not
say these films are inhuman in any way
or whatever films you feel match this
criteria it just emphasizes what a
variety of both subtlety and extremes
were offered whether they be good bad to
bad or to good I feel like I can't be
alone in noticing this in certain movies
but as always all art is subjective so
tell me in the comments below what films
you've come across that left a similar
experience the films that you know
should be phenomenal but don't feel
phenomenal to you for some reason even
though nothing seems to be wrong I'm not
saying they need to be judged or
ridiculed but they can at least be
explored what film should have left you
bawling with emotion but for an almost
unexplainable reason didn't what puzzle
had all the correct pieces but didn't
click together let's see if there's
really something to a tale being too
perfectly told listen below talk about
him and see if anyone else can
understand this realm of being perfectly
flawed
I'm gonna stash your credit Guy remember
it so you don't have to let's do this
coming next week it's the review of
Ghostbusters 2016 time to see what all
the fuss is about but you can see it now
under vessel's ad free early access just
three dollars a month to see tons of
people's videos early as well as a bunch
of other extra features check it out and
get the early scoop
hey don't walk are here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the American kidney fund this is
the nation's leading nonprofit working
on behalf of the 31 million Americans
with kidney disease their mission is to
help people fight kidney disease and
live healthier lives and they fulfill
that mission by providing a complete
spectrum of programs services with
prevention activities top-rated health
educational resources and direct
financial assistance enabling one in
five US kidney patients to access
life-saving medical care they invest in
clinical research to improve outcomes
for kidney patients and fight tirelessly
on Capitol Hill for legislation and
policy supporting the issues they're
important to people that they certainly
and this year they are celebrating their
45th anniversary with 63,000 individuals
corporations and foundations whose
charitable support sustains their
mission they spend over ninety seven
cents of every donated dollar on
programs that directly serve and educate
patients and the public and yes they got
an a-plus on charity ratings the highest
rating you can get you can check out
their website or their YouTube channel
to see not only all the good work that
they're doing but how you can help
continue that good work go check it out
and see the big difference you can make